the taoist tradition is a deep and
diverse one it has played and continues
to play a decisive role in the religious
landscape of china and
in spite of this fact a lot of the
material we find on taoism especially in
non-chinese language is often hugely
oversimplified there's a tendency to
focus only on the earliest taoist
authors like lao tzu and the dao de jing
and dranza and the
well dranzer these sages only one of
whom probably existed historically is
often exalted as the true
representatives of pure taoism and any
later developments in the sort of
post-classical period is often either
downplayed or outright ignored even i in
my earlier episode about taoism lean
very heavily into the classical period
in particular
i did promise then that i was going to
deliver more episodes about the later
developed taoist tradition and finally
today i am going to deliver on that
promise
[Music]
it is indeed true that most people are
familiar only with the classical taoist
text like the dao de jing and dranzel
partly because scholarship on the topic
has almost exclusively focused on that
period
these texts were composed somewhere
between the 4th to 2nd centuries bc but
after all most of the history of taoism
and its development takes place after
this and some of its most fundamental
features only appear in these later
periods as mentioned in the earlier
episode many have tended to divide
taoism into philosophical taoism or
doujia and religious taoism dao zhao the
former being associated with the
classical texts and their authors and
the latter with the more organized forms
of taoism that developed in later
centuries
thankfully scholars today have begun to
heavily criticize this division and in
my opinion it is for the most part
untenable today as pointed out by louis
come jethy this division of
philosophical versus religious taoism is
a colonialist and orientalist legacy
that has stuck and pervades the
discussion even today
a highly inaccurate interpretation that
views quote unquote philosophical taoism
as the original or pure version that was
later forgotten or replaced with
religious superstition in later periods
in comedy's own words quote such a
bifurcated interpretation of taoism is
flawed and inaccurate
it involves a systematic
misunderstanding and misinterpretation
of classical taoism usually through
selective readings of inaccurate
translations of classical taoist texts
reference to so-called philosophical
taoism and or religious taoism should be
taken ipso facto as inaccuracy and
misunderstanding with respect to the
taoist tradition
this inaccurate view of taoism is not
only based on misreading the ancient or
classical taoist text but also leads to
further misunderstandings and skewed
interpretations that do not line up with
the perspectives and interpretations
within the taoist tradition itself with
that said however there is no denying
that there was a change in the way that
taoism was organized from the classical
periods and into later periods of the
more organized forms of taoism and of
course developments took place in terms
of beliefs and practices we often talk
about this period of the early taoist
writers as classical taoism which was
very loosely organized now it wasn't
completely unorganized as many have
assumed previously instead we see
evidence in text like the drones that
the so-called taoists of his time belong
to lineages of teacher student
initiation and that similar ideas and
practices were observed by these groups
scholars have opted to call these inner
cultivation lineages that existed around
china the primary practices of these
classical taoists were perhaps more
centrally a kind of apophatic meditation
where one emptied oneself completely in
order to become united with the tao to
experience the oneness of the tao that
underlies all reality as well as other
related practices and things like
asceticism for example
and there seems to be a direct line
connecting these classical taoists with
the organized forms of the religion that
appeared later in history that thing
that so many have called quote-unquote
religious taoism indeed the more
formally organized forms of this
religion only appeared in the later han
dynasty specifically around the second
century a.d and by then some significant
developments had already taken place
what is often considered the first form
of organized taoism was called tianxi
dao or the way of the celestial masters
it was founded by the figure zhang dao
ling who after receiving a revelation
from lao joon or lao tzu in deified form
established a taoist movement where he
was given the title and role of
celestial master a leadership role that
was then inherited in a patrilineal
succession until today
by this point as we saw the figure of
laozi attributed as the author of the
famous dao de jing had become seen as a
deity and would come to hell a central
position in the pantheon of taoist gods
we can see that being given a revelation
from lao tzu as zhang dao ling did give
him a very high status and similar
revelations would play a major role in
later taoist movements across history
the way of these celestial masters also
called jengi orthodox unity and wudumi
dao the way of the five packs of rice
became one of the cornerstones of the
taoist tradition and today it remains
one of the two main schools of taoism in
china but that's the thing over the
coming centuries during the han and tang
dynasties there continued to appear many
different forms of organized taoism
taoist movements distinct from tianxi or
the way of the celestial masters that
nonetheless play that important role
and some of the most prominent of these
include tai ching chang ching and ling
bao
and as already mentioned by this time
new practices and ideas had emerged and
continued to emerge and develop
the concept of the dao was always a kind
of unifying factor as well as the
general world view that goes along with
it for more on that you should watch my
earlier episode on taoism in terms of
practice as we saw earlier the classical
taoist had primarily focused on a kind
of apophatic meditation as well as
different grades and levels of
asceticism you could say but by the
later periods new perspectives new
practices new ideas had emerged
surrounding things like
death and the afterlife for example
judging by classical texts like the
dranzer the perspective that these
earlier texts have towards the
individual self and death
seem to be one where the self is made up
of a bunch of composite parts and that
upon death the individual simply dies
and is absorbed into the totality of the
universe everything is the dao of course
including our innermost reality and as
the dao we will always survive as the
one totality of all things when the
practitioner has reached a mystical
union with the dao he realizes the
illusory nature of separate existence
but as an individual person there is no
clear postmortem life quote once one
attained disappearance of self and
abided in the dao one came to understand
that death and life are part of the same
transformative process
nonetheless death was still the end of
personhood and terrestrial being
one dies and death is nothingness on a
personal level
as an example in response to his wife
dying and some companions asking why he
isn't mourning anymore drunca says quote
when she first died do you think i
didn't grieve like anyone else but i
look back to her beginning and the time
before she was born
not only the time before she was born
but the time before she had a body
not only the time before she had a body
but the time before she had a spirit
in the midst of the jumble of wandering
mystery a change took place and she had
a spirit
another change and she had a body
another change and she was born
now there has been another change and
she's dead
it's just like the progression of the
four seasons spring summer fall winter
death is as natural as the turning of
the seasons and one should accept that
fate as part of the way of the tao
but later on new perspectives seem to
have developed they never strayed from
this original perspective of course but
the taoist also started to conceive of
different ways that one might be able to
bring together the different aspects of
the compass itself and through that
reach a kind of immortality the word
used for a person reaching this state is
tian ren which is most often translated
as immortal but it can also mean
something like ascendant or transcendent
there is some disagreement on how this
concept has been understood by the
taoist as either an earthly immortality
or as a more kind of spiritual abstract
postmortem existence but this cult of
immortality nonetheless became one of
the key features of later organized
taoism it is from this that the fung shi
the formula masters and different forms
of daout alchemy appears as such an
important part of taoist practice which
it remains to this day
taoist alchemy very famous and yet often
deemed as part of the less admired
category of religious taoism is key to
understanding the tradition as a whole
this quest for immortality wasn't unique
to taoism of course but became a trend
in china from the early han dynasty
there are stories of emperors who sent
people to the far shores of the world to
find the secret to immortality and many
other such stories but in taoism it
would develop into a very complex and
significant tradition
the earliest form of alchemy was the
external kind called why don
in other words the kind of alchemy that
most people think of when they hear the
word alchemy this consisted of the
concoction of various elixirs and other
substances that were thought to lead to
immortality
in any case external alchemy like this
continued to play a major role and there
was a lot of fascinating stuff to
explore there but
later another form of alchemy would
prove even more popular in what is often
called the period of late organized
taoism including in the later tang
dynasty song ming and qing dynasties we
see more significant changes in the
religion
the appearance of buddhism in china
proved very influential not only on
society at large but on taoism as a
religion as well
while there were periods of animosity
between these two religions we can also
see how the two traditions would greatly
influence each other chan buddhism known
in japan as zen buddhism is greatly
influenced by taoist ideas and in the
later middle ages we also see how taoism
becomes increasingly influenced by
buddhism as well it is for example here
that taoism developed a form of
monasticism similar to the monks and
nuns of buddhism and thus encouraged
further change in its organization
taoist priests and monks started
practicing things like celibacy and
communal monastic living something that
was not the norm in earlier periods in
this later period we also see the
emergence of more organized taoist
movements most prominently the tron chen
the way of complete perfection a highly
monastic form of organized taoism
heavily influenced by buddhism which
today makes up the majority form of
taoism in china followed by the way of
the celestial masters mentioned earlier
and it is also in this period that we
see the development of internal alchemy
nadan which would become one of the
primary forms of taoist practice going
forward
it is this very fascinating and deep
tradition that we will focus on for the
rest of this discussion
internal alchemy or naidon is just like
external alchemy a set of ideas and
techniques with the ultimate aim of
transforming the inner self so that it
can reach immortality but here it isn't
done through elixirs and other external
means but instead through what we could
broadly call spiritual practices the
alchemical change does not come from the
outside but from a transformation from
the inside out
this practice is part of the wider
spiritual techniques of taoism and
strongly connected and related to other
practices like the apathetic meditation
that i mentioned earlier various forms
of visualization dietary restrictions
and general asceticism the tradition of
internal alchemy has always been kind of
esoteric it is highly dependent on being
taught the proper techniques of internal
alchemy from a qualified teacher and the
language that is used is often highly
symbolic
mysterious and even occult it uses
symbolic terms taken from external
alchemy and uses these external
alchemical terms to explain different
inner states and
aspects of the self for example the
lower abdomen is referred to as the
elixir field the heart is called the
scarlet palace and so on
this language is probably partly a
conscious way of keeping the teachings
esoteric but also has a very nice poetic
ring to it
thankfully though we get writings from
the late imperial era of china that
actually explain and provide detailed
descriptions of some of the techniques
of internal alchemy from this it becomes
clear that it is a tradition that is
again strongly connected to other
currents within taoism in particular but
also within chinese culture and religion
in general
there are elements from classical taoist
texts meditation techniques external
alchemy chinese medicine and even
symbology from the yi ching or book of
changes what these practices of internal
alchemy is all about is once again to
reach that state of immortality through
uniting the different elements of the
human self in order to fully grasp these
techniques and the theories surrounding
them we have to try to understand three
key concepts in the psychology of taoism
and chinese cosmology referred to as the
internal three treasures
these are jing
vital essence qi and shen
i'm sure that you've heard some of these
words in different contexts before and
if that context is in hollywood movies
like mulan then you basically need to
forget everything that you know
jing is often translated as vital
essence it is as the name suggests the
basic vitality of the person associated
with things like sexual reproduction
chi is probably the most famous word and
often most misunderstood it is sometimes
translated as vital breath as energy or
even as pneuma or spirit and none of
these are very accurate it is a kind of
subtle animating force that which gives
everything life which is why many have
understood it as a kind of energy
qi exists everywhere in all things and
in all people everything is chi in a way
so it's not something that you can get
with something that is always part of
your constitution
but there are different kinds of chi and
different grades of chi
some qi that is much more coarse and
substantial and qi that is more subtle
and thus associated with things like
deities and other subtle realities it
comes from a word that also literally
means breath as in the as in breathing
which is why some people have also
connected it to the greek term pneuma
which also means breath but also means
something like a spirit but we should be
careful to draw too many comparisons
like this right but it's important to
know that qi well it means this essence
and this life-giving force that exists
everywhere also can mean literally
regular breath and lastly there is shen
which is often translated as spirit this
is the most subtle part of the human
being even more subtle than qi and thus
it is the part that can connect with
other subtle divine realities and is
associated with consciousness itself
these three treasures are central to the
practice of naidan indeed at its most
general level it is said that internal
alchemy consists of a three-stage
process
first transforming vital essence into qi
two transforming qi into shen
and three merging spirit or shen with
the void
so as you can tell internal alchemy
consists of cultivating the three
treasures of uniting these different
aspects of the self into an increasingly
more subtle unified whole and then
finally merging that unity with the
absolute oneness of the void or the tao
pretty poetic stuff and the language
used in many texts describing naidon
practices uses that very poetic and
esoteric language that i talked about
earlier just listen to this section from
the wu zheng pyang the awakening to
perfection written by zhang bodwan quote
harmonize your inner lead and mercury to
produce the elixir whether big or small
there is no harm both areas are quite
safe
if you wonder what the true lead may be
it is moonlight shining every day on the
western river before you have refined
the reverted elixir do not enter the
mountains since on the mountains in and
out there is no lead for you
rather the supreme treasure is in
everybody's home
it's just that folk are ignorant and
never recognize it
when bamboo breaks use bamboo to repair
it
to hatch a chicken use an egg
to match up different species is a waste
of effort much better add to your
spiritual potential with true lead
the white tiger in the western mountains
begins to go wild the green dragon in
the eastern sea is no match for him
both beasts interlock and fight hard to
the death they turn into a mass of
purple golden frost
on the peak of sacred flower mountain
the male tiger roars at the bottom of
sun mulberry ocean the female dragon
howls the matchmaker of the center
spontaneously knows how to join them
together they become husband and wife
sharing the same core
when the half moon rises bright over the
horizon and you hear the dragon howl the
tiger roar immediately apply your mind
well to cultivate the two for eight more
cycles within an hour you can see the
elixir take shape inside
what does any of this mean
no idea but it shows you the kind of
poetic and very symbolic language that
is often used to describe these
different internal alchemical
techniques and and ideas but how is this
naidan done on a actual practical level
well luckily as i said earlier we do
have writings from the later imperial
period in china that actually describe
some of these practices in great detail
even though for most of history they
have been quite secretive and esoteric
two of the most significant figures of
late taoism include leo yiming and leo
hua yang who both give us significant
writings about internal alchemy
the latter figure was also strongly
connected with buddhism and wrote a work
called
scripture on wisdom and life destiny in
which he divides the alchemical process
into eight stages
one the cessation of outflow
two the six phases of the dharma wheel
three connecting the governing and
conception channels
four coalescing the embryo of the dao or
immoral embryo
five sending out of the fetus
six manifesting the transformation body
seven facing the wall
and eight disappearance into the void
now notice the buddhist influences here
it's very clear
in some ways this is a more elaborate
version of the three-step process
mentioned earlier which goes through the
entire process the first step is to
conserve qi and spirit by abstaining
from various things like emotional
attachment sensory stimulation and
sexual activity
this stores qi and spirit in the
abdominal region aside from this the
body is thought to have various
different energetic pathways or
meridians and organs connected to each
other
the following steps are complex and i'm
better off just leaving it to our friend
comedy to explain it himself quote then
one must activate the water wheel or
microcosmic orbits that is connect the
governing vessel along the center line
of the back with the conception vessel
along the center line of the torso this
is done by circulating qi up the back
and down the front of the body so that
the body becomes an integrated energetic
hole so that one activates the taoist
subtle body
through this process in concert with the
cultivation of stillness one becomes a
spiritually integrated and transformed
being
this whole thing is often described very
poetically and symbolically through the
fetus of the dao
once one starts the alchemical process
the embryo of immortality is born in the
womb which eventually grows into a full
fetus which is then sent out in the
fifth stage listed liu hua yang then
describes the final stage of the process
in various ways using both taoist and
buddhist language as called completing
the immortal fetus as attaining buddha
form as returning to the source and even
as disappearing into the void in other
words one becomes united with the tao
all of these practices are done often
while sitting down in a kind of
meditation position the illustrations
suggest that the lotus position was the
common posture to use and that one
should ideally sit in a quiet and empty
place
quote your meditation room should be
located in a place where you will not be
disturbed
when you meditate forget form after
entering stillness forget the heart mind
return the radiance and revert
illumination
let original nature enter the palace of
life destiny
in this way original nature and life
destiny will be cultivated
simultaneously
in general the esoteric practice of
naidan or internal alchemy has remained
a cornerstone of daoist practice since
it first emerged in the late tang
dynasty and the song dynasty in the
middle ages up until this very day it
sits alongside other practices of taoism
like the more ritualized and ceremonial
offerings to the gods by
taoist priests to more individualized
practices like apathetic meditation
visualization techniques
dietary restrictions and even the
fascinating
practice that is known as guarding the
one which we should probably dedicate a
future episode to and indeed there will
be further opportunities to discuss
these different practices and other
aspects of taoism both early taoism and
later organize taoism in future episodes
in this episode we have primarily
focused on two topics number one we have
discussed the
in a very general sense the organized
forms of taoism that developed from the
later han dynasty and forward as well as
critiquing a lot of the
orientalist and colonialist perspectives
on taoism and the
difference between philosophical and
religious taoism for example to give a
better more nuanced view of this deep
and very fascinating tradition and
secondly we have explored the world of
internal alchemy or nadan in chinese
which has at least from the later middle
ages from the song dynasty or so
been one of the main features and main
practices in taoism until today i hope
you are as excited as i am to keep
exploring this deep and colorful
tradition as well as to dispel some of
the many misconceptions about it
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you